hello in the welcome mat and see your
planes meta oh aight i have the same
damn I have some kind of opening against
this guy with a black that I always have
and with Whiteside oh maybe this one get
the semi to rush maybe getting into an
IQ p position quite likely that it takes
on default hour for like you p we should
be seven now as the normal field now
black has a choice Knight f6 takes on c3
hmm you should have six or B 6 i'm not
sure that this is correct team okay
interesting i can take hero in the trap
that looks like a bit of temperament of
time and now this is a slightly awkward
pin I think all right or isn't it let's
see how to handle this here hmm it looks
it looks awkward definitely but 95 is a
bit irritating I would like to play um i
would like to play the Queen Nia 95
would be cool to get in but I don't see
how exactly this is possible so maybe
maybe some normals
yeah I oh okay hmm didn't take that into
account that much hmm I should have
probably
yeah Brooksie one hand I don't like to
but I probably have to take with the
bishop I don't see having any comp I
don't have any compensation I think
otherwise okay here i can take first on
CA it this is good so it probably has to
take with this bishop okay so he allows
me to worsen his bone structure maybe
it's not a big deal i am it's certainly
possible i'm going to get to that right
away let's have a approach this king of
it
king j qg for Jack cross-screen g4 here
between age five he has a queen to F for
some probably Queen here and for a
temple and watch now
yeah maybe before that would kick the
night back and now I was thinking d5 as
interesting takes and Bishop d3 or
Bishop d3 immediately either 97 but if i
take Bishop d3 brooke Lee 8 as a move
this is also a bit awkward okay I can
also start with this chick and approach
like that this is actually interesting
this he takes it and then Queen g4 check
yeah it's not really nothing that much
but ok it's still this puts him under
some pressure this d5 move check queen
king h8 I may be Queen f5 and I Queen f5
is interesting this is interesting so
maybe found something interesting but it
took me awhile to actually understand
why it is interesting these are the
really good muscle okay so it didn't
dare to take it
so what am i doing now probably taking
here right don't know I guess I'll take
oh he thought 94 would be interesting
and let's see maybe maybe he can go but
I Queen d6s rookie one it's not really
that nice for is going to g6 I guess
yeah you can go to g6 it's still quite
not easy to break down and put maybe
this one intending f4
I don't like to break this attack on the
aged six porn that I think f4 is a
sufficiently strong thread here
match is six Queen g4s end of game 93
that's 23
general Queen g3 Queen g6 is very
dangerous so the only thing that's kind
of troubling is that default is somehow
hanging with a check in a way but I
don't see how I exploits this okay so
here I was thinking the check and Queen
to g6 so maybe he has hmm Jackie let's
play that first 26 he has this capture
here
time morning
is that not winning somehow that's kind
of hard to believe there isn't something
okay I'm going to do this maybe it's
entirely wrong and then green g6 yes
Queen f forward maybe the save some it's
possible that screen d find all kinds of
counter play then might be might be I
have to check i have to check check
check check check check check check
check now this is so draw check okay DRA
offered check hey you want to decline a
check game drug now we click the
repetition of the draw button for the
repetition yeah so okay he saved it that
was I think I like this i think it
wasn't well a badly played and I
certainly sports something there ok well
i will have a look so how did that work
he went here and this is this it seems
ok and now this d5 when i went differ
the computer won't stand this first and
then go to five and after this Queen
there okay it looks quite similar to I
now it takes is six ok imma checking
this okay but what about what I played
and I have a hard time to believe that
it shouldn't be good for something
yeah computer gives me an edge but not
not a win or anything and now it gives
me a win check yes this oh no actually
oh I can check and check here okay and
then take you six yeah okay this is
pretty good right yeah this is very good
hmm ok so this was the thing this is
just the draw I was kind of thinking
that it might just be but I didn't want
to spend no ages and don't get anywhere
and at the end I was just like gambling
that it this might not be a draw but it
is a draw check check no I was actually
thinking that this also could be good
maybe I know I have to take the draw
with the with the perpetual it's
probably difficult not to perpetual yeah
I guess I'd okay I had a win somewhere
but i think he defended as well okay
thanks for watching